[Music]
mrs griffin your pregnancy is
endangering your life mom
what's the treatment to not be pregnant
that's the only option we can ask the
board for permission to perform an
emergency termination
is there a chance that she could survive
the pregnancy maybe 50 resulting in the
birth of a healthy child i'm here i'm
i'm right here
i hope now gentlemen no no no no
no
[Music]
this is jane how does it work
joy yes get in
no this is not a taxi you sit up front
with me
[Music]
you're gonna rest for a few hours which
one of you is jane
we're all jane
we have organizing meetings that's the
address
how are we going to get through them all
this 11 year old girl deserves it well
this lady has cancer she was raped it
has to be random it's life or death for
some of them it's life or death for all
of them
take a deep breath you got a knack for
this could have been a nurse could have
been a doctor
we are entirely dependent on one man we
can't change what it costs joy it's
economics it's interesting how economics
always seems to mean that black women
get screwed stand up stand up
so tell me how you ladies came to be
jane my wife's name is joy detective hey
you told me that
you want to end up in prison
i will answer any questions i don't want
to know
[Music]
we have something that works we are of
use yeah it's not perfect but it works
i'm not scared of jail i'm scared there
won't be anyone left to answer the phone
i need help i don't know what to do this
is my fourth message i'm losing my grip
i can't tell my parents
they have to go back
[Music]
[Music]